les signes du mal sont omniprésents il y
a désormais ce monstre j'ai pensé que tu
pourrais nous protéger j'étais marqué
notre monde est déchiré entre la lumière
et les ténèbres tuer le septième fils du
septième fils et qu'elle est donc notre
rôle depuis l'aube des temps
nous protégeons l'humanité apprends moi
rathier que d'humanité scabreux
mal pris racine en ce gâteau ils se
servent de toit
il est environ aux puciers
pourquoi choisir les humains
si tu vois une sorcière tu là ne
s'aiment pas toutes magnifiques ici
c'est la plus importante de thé épreuve
sers toi de tout ce que je t'ai appris
très bas ce que tu es là
c'est immonde c'est pourquoi la lâcheté